[Musique]
le projet
complexe et inédit
que nous lançons ce jour marque une
étape majeure
dans la matérialisation du plan sénégal
émergent
oui
on est obligé de se conformer à la
décision de l'état mais nous notre
souhait c'était de rester et continuer
nos activités et que l'usld une puce
aller ailleurs
[Musique]
oui
qu'est ce que le degré de salinité de
ventes a augmenté ce qu'ils savent
apparaît plus les poissons auparavant
pourront voir ici les passions aussi les
balles poisson ici sur la place ici mais
maintenant on est obligé d'aller
beaucoup plus loin coupures et des
poissons donc avec les unes qui va
donner mais sur quelles seront les
conséquences un jour
[Musique]